so all of these things are the same
they're all different ways our slicing
up the same pie and taking these both
together allows us to deal with things
like this and also allows us to deal
with now this is one which I'm I sort of
mentioned to some of you before but it's
such a famous result that I'm going to
show all of you ok so here's an example
of an entry but that's going to use both
of these properties thank you
so this is a very young it's a very
famous integral and by the end of this
you'll see why now before we get started
on this I want to know what this thing
is what does it look like just think out
the integrand for me okay as X
approaches Europe as X approaches zero
what is happening to this interval to
the M to the denominator insanity is
approaching as X approaches zero what's
the denominator the denominator is also
approaching zero yes
so therefore as X approaches zero this
thing is approaching infinity but of
course I have to say as it approaches
because you can't evaluate it at zero
can you write in fact let's just draw
the picture because of that square root
of x it's on the denominator you've got
an asymptote there okay you might think
oh I might have an asymptote from here
as well but you don't need to worry
about that why not this guy's not even
defined like that for the negative part
that oh the domain for this is X is
greater than zero because in this way so
book that that's fine okay tell me about
what happens now as X approaches
infinity what's happening to the
denominator the denominator the
denominator is going to infinity yeah
the denominator so therefore the whole
function is getting really really small
so therefore and isn't it you know
something to stop that okay so you've
got that now I'm going to do it on a
gross oversimplification of this you're
looking at something like this I mean
I've drawn it looks exactly like the
regular you know the rectangular
hyperbola
but the curvature is different enough
that we get a different result out of
this okay so what am i interested in I'm
interested in this area the entire area
bounded by not just the x axis but the y
axis as well so this this here is an
uncomfortable way of writing things
right because we know it's like you
shouldn't be
do that right these clearly implies
limit notation okay so what I'm gonna
take advantage of is this line in here
I am going to break up this function
into two pieces
right and that will give me two
different boundaries that will have two
different limits so what's convenient to
me like I want to choose a value in the
middle that's going to be nice and when
you excuse me have a look at this it
just so happens that choosing one is a
nice convenient value between north and
you can choose anything if you like but
it will just make it easy for me to
about it once I have a primitive
function okay so I'm going to go from
nought to one but instead of writing not
to one I'm going to use this limitation
because I really actually can't get to
North right you see that so I'm gonna
say let's go from say you to one okay
and see what happens as u approaches
zero okay so this is my my first part of
the interval it's one on an X plus one X
let me just make two X there's naught to
one kind off now I'm gonna do one to
infinity
Clinton okay so I'm gonna go limit as u
approaches infinity but I've now got the
upper boundary is the one that I'm
replacing with a limit so now I'm going
one to you and it's the same integrand
okay now step you off to the side for a
bit because this doesn't look like a
standard thing I'm gonna need to make a
substitution of some kind that will make
this easy to integrate it so would
someone have to make a suggestion
what could I let u equal to or they
don't know better than chosen you what
should i what's opposition should I
choose here in order make this easier
turn you're doing X plus 1 equals okay
so my first choice is my first race is
like I've got a products down here on
the denominator so I think it's gonna be
one of these okay that's a lot of bad
gifts now if I wait for him to us one
what would happen I would do you might
be you or DX interchange my variable
togethers what is to your DX 1 well
that's fine I have a 1 there but once
you replace this how are you going to
replace this rune X what's it going to
be yeah so what you're doing in fact is
if you say don't understand if you let u
equal X plus 1 right then order to get
something for this
whatever your duty you're going to turn
this into u minus 1 equals x so then
rune x equals root of U minus 1 so in
fact what I have now ended up with is
actually not much better than what is
what I've started with yeah because I'm
now going to be integrating instead of
this I'll be integrating u times the
square root of U minus 1 which is
essentially the same problem okay so
that's not going to work very much for
me and one of the ways you could have
known that it's not going to usually
work is because if you're do you want
the x equals 1 that means essentially
there's no difference between what
you're differentiating your what you're
integrating with respect you now first
of what you're integrating with this
actually things choose you okay which is
why even though it's like oh it's a bit
of a pain when you do you and yet
there's a minus 4 it turns into treat
functions or whatever that's actually
the whole point if there's no
substantial change then there's no
substantial advantage okay